hello welcome to part two
of our presentation on the site and
locations planned preferred options
consultation
uh hopefully for those who've watched
part one you found it
interesting um in this part i want to
cover the
remaining chapters in the cyto locations
plan so
that are those are chapters four
orbital very boundaries five employment
enabling
six the a46 and seven the site specific
proposals again uh this is live i
haven't got a script so
we'll see how we go um
and uh yeah hopefully uh you'll find it
uh useful um
we've done a number of summary videos as
well uh which
a bit more bite-sized
if you want to look at those they're on
our website at stratfor.gov dot uk
sappo um and again the plan itself does
contain
explanatory information um setting up
why we're
um proposing the policy approach we are
but say hopefully this presentation
i would would have given to parish
councils um
is is of use as well so let's see
if i can achieve the start button last
time yes
um this is the contents of the start
allocations plan or sap
so i've really come off uh chapters two
and three in part one
and said uh chapters four five six and
seven
uh are in this presentation um again all
the
all the maps from all the chapters in
chapter eight
uh which i won't deal with and just to
retreat that there are
four appendices and four annexes to the
site allocations plan
and again uh remind you that the policy
numbers proposal references and site
references
may have changed since the last year
when we have the proposed submission
version site allocations planned
but that version has been withdrawn this
preferred options version uh replaces
that version
it's a similar structure but the content
is slightly different
hence why the um the references may have
changed
so let's get cracking
um again just to recap uh in case you
haven't uh
seen part one uh
we are we're at preferred options stage
we're consulting
to the 18th of december so please do
send us in your comments
we'll then take those on board make any
changes and you'll look to
agree a new proposed submission version
next april
and again consult on that for six weeks
and
we'll then uh take those comments on
board make any changes and before we
formally submit
the psychiatrist plan uh to the
government
for independent examination so because
it's uh
psycho cash's plan is a legal legal
plan for the district we have to have it
examined in public
by the independent planning spectre um i
hope that would be spring 2022 and then
all being well uh if the inspector is
happy with the plan
we can adopt
use the plan properly to determine our
applications from 2022
onwards um if we can do it quicker we
will
so that's a a reasonable timetable from
the various stages
we've got to got to go through so
um preferred options are very much a
sort of draft stage
for an early stage in the process and so
certainly at least one other
consultation
early next year on the plan so we're
we're asking questions in this plan uh
about our approach
and saying nothing's nothing
agreed or um signed off yet
um this is simply a consultation um
at all those uh next stage so proposed
submission again
um full council members of the strapping
council would agree
the uh the plan for consultation and
again
uh full council members of stratford
council would
agree to formally submit the plan uh
to the government so again there's still
some stages of democratic accountability
to to run through
so plan preparation is not a quick
process
it has to go through these very
situations and various consultations
which
make it a better plan um
[Music]
from taking account of the views of uh
communities and stakeholders right
so um this was chapter four built up
area boundaries
um the
the point of built-up area boundaries or
blue abs
is to distinguish between land within
the viewable within the boundary where
the principle of development so
whether you can do you can you know
build
let's say a new house for example
is acceptable uh from
the land outside the built up area where
we're saying
you shouldn't build a house to put in
simple terms
um obviously there's still you still
have to meet all this
specific design criteria all
the other coming requirements but the
principle of whether you can actually
do development or not um is established
is acceptable within the boundary um
whereas we're trying to preserve the
countryside from encroachment
that's why we have a much stricter
approach um
with a few nato exceptions to saying no
you shouldn't build new houses um in the
countryside
as a general rule of thumb so
a number of villages have already got
built up every boundary either
established in the core strategy or
their neighbourhood plan uh and
certainly if they've done it through the
major plan we don't want to
do it again we're quite happy with that
boundary and so this is
almost a mopping up exercise um
to to identify boundaries for those
settlements that don't yet
have one and they're there
they're listed there so that's the the
the point of your sub-area boundaries
okay um next chapter chapter five i
think
uh it's policy sap eight
uh this is a uh a new approach
uh when we're trialing uh in stratford
um and it it sort of comes from the fact
that the
the evidence we we're hearing from
[Music]
the um the business community uh
stakeholders is that there does seem to
be a shortage of
um affordable and the key word there is
affordable
affordable uh employment spaces and
premises for businesses to grow and
expand onto
and that seems to be um happening
because
the the new employment sites that we've
provided through the core strategy
are um are being
are being built but they're they're
going to like high-end
uh occupiers and tenants who can afford
and say top top dollar for it
um at the other end of the spectrum the
um
the cheaper employment space um
is being lost to have other um
higher end user uses like residential
and that's perhaps being driven by the
government's desire to
encourage ground field regeneration so
if you like the middle is being squeezed
because
at both ends the supply of say
affordable employment spaces
is being lost so what we're trying to do
is
uh provide additional websites on sites
that we wouldn't
otherwise grant consent for um
so these are um these would be if you
like windfall
allocated sites they're not the
important sites already
in the core strategy these are
additional sites
and they'd have to satisfy a whole raft
of the planning criteria
but we feel like we're loosening the
rains slightly
and saying okay if it's for employment
use then
we'll we'll accept the principle we're
doing on these sites
the payback if you like is that in
return we will get some
affordable employment floor space
provided at um
rate lower than market rent so certainly
high percent of market rates so that
we can provide that excuse me to local
businesses
and help businesses grow and say whilst
this approach didn't originate
um or originated before covid i think
the fact that we're
dealing with a global pandemic when the
economy
needs um strengthening
um i think this is a really useful um
and sensible approach to try and boost
the local economy and say
okay let's provide additional space for
our businesses to
to grow and expand onto so say a new
approach
and be grateful to hear your views uh
about it really
and uh hopefully there'll be some take
up
okay so uh chapter six is the
a46 safeguarding
um two sites um or two areas of land
rather
the top one there is um the world more
uh junction so both sides are on the a46
just
on to the north northern edge of
stratford-upon-avon town
at the top one there is the wild moon
junction
and the uh road to ulster
um and then the bottom one there so i'm
just looking at my map on the left there
and the bottom one there is the bishops
and junction
which the road uh to to henley
um what we're proposing is to
to safeguard those areas land shown um
and uh to bring forward
uh for junction improvements uh should
funding
be made available i ought to stress that
there is no
funding yet available for these works
we're trying to think
long term we're trying to future proof
the infrastructure in this district and
say
okay when that when and if that funding
is available
uh we've got the land um available to um
to implement those improvements that's
what we uh
chapter six is about say grateful for
views
on those
um chapter seven is uh a list of
14 specific site proposals
um many of these features in the last
version of
the site applications plan but there are
some
new ones so let's run through them
so sites proposals sua 2 and sua4
these are actually employment sites that
are in the in the core strategy
but what we want to do is just update
the policy requirements to affect the um
the latest situation so
that's why we're uh repeating them if
you like in the
insight allocations plan so the
one left is uh south of worcester road
which is um close so just south of
the junction we looked at on the a46
and then the one on the right is the uh
site atherton airfield
at just the southeast uh or southwest of
stratford town itself
so both the principle both
is established in the course strategy
we're just tweaking the uh
policy requirements
okay so sua5 this is a new site um
and if you listen to uh
part one of the presentation i would
have referred to it
um the um it's it's been
twisted on its access so uh north is to
the right just to get our bearings
so uh north is to the right and uh
the say weight trays in the roseburg
center
is that development uh immediately to
the right hand side
or north of the site
so it's south of south of the roseburg
center east of
shipston road and we are proposing
employment land to relocate some
businesses
from wolf road in in the canal quarter
to here
that will enable facilitate
uh wolf road to come forward for
development so
wolf road in the center of town is
identified as part of our
canal quarter regeneration zone and the
businesses there
need to relocate somewhere and they've
advised they need to relocate
south of the town
and we're providing land to help
facilitate that and then bring forward
the
the wider canal quarter regeneration
so this site is also adjacent to the
reserve site
sdr dot b which is i covered in in part
one
of the plan but it's it's there to
facilitate
relocation of existing businesses keep
them in the town
and also regenerate the canal quarter
um
um proposal is six um
so this is a an area of land um
it's a bit of a heavy street uh
arden street some green little green
hill street
um and it's it's trying to
encourage coordinate and facilitate uh
regeneration of this area
and some of it is
a little bit run down um something
that's a bit underused
um and it's it's just trying to
um improve the quality of the part realm
and provide better use bringing in some
more uses whether it's um office
some retail commercial measure uses
um and it's yeah certainly that the top
end
facing onto the birmingham road and is
this whole key
sort of gateway uh into the town centre
and it's very non-descriptive at the
moment it's just really
injected um road junction
and there's no sense of you've arrived
um
so stratfor this is such an
actually important town um
so we think by trying to coordinate
development here
we can get a better public realm
we can also get a
um introduce new uses into the town
um and so you can generate this this
part of the town sensor
as well uh so that's uh n286
so grateful for use your comments on
this one and
the range of uses uh through
um
um pedestrian routes through through the
site
to get better access so from the bus
station coach station
uh to any streets as well so um yes very
grateful for reviews on
this one please um two sites here so the
one on the left
is sua 8 which is grade road
on the street which is literally just
south of where we've been looking
again same principles apply and
say to uh i mean part of this is has
always been
already being redeveloped um
i think it's right to
is its regeneration on this part of the
town centre as well
and then sra 9 south of worcester road
this is the
uh actually the car park um for
stratford on avon college
um we're looking to safeguard
car park for a use for the school
and it may well retain its use as car
parking
but that would enable the existing
school sites to expand as well
that'll help remedy summary capacity
problems um
facing the school in the town in terms
of secondary education
and so we think this is the right site
to try and uh
safeguard for education uses again
thoughts on that one please
be welcome this is a new proposal in
pittsford
uh corner of waterloo road and
wellington road
um bitchwood has expanded
um probably exponentially over the last
few years
um away from his historic
small historic high street um
proposing a sort of new village centre
essentially
in bidford uh some uh sort of
civic space um as well as retail and
commercial
spaces and that might then enable the
the existing historic high street
excuse me to be repurposed for perhaps
more of a leisure
destination um but again thoughts
uh welcome on on this one um
whether this is the the right approach
for this site
in pittsford
uh similarly uh stud one in studly just
stopping center just
off the high street again uh we want to
try and regenerate this this area land
um
vastly improve the public realm with
this site there are a number of existing
thriving businesses
on site they own the land and what we're
trying to do is coordinate and would
work with those landowners
to improve the public ground perhaps um
or give them
uh new premises um as well as
say provide that commercial space or um
civic space
for the residence country to have
you know their functions um as well as
additional employment space and retail
and residential uses
uh to give a new brief uh new life to
this part of study
will only work if we can work with
existing landowners
and by having a coordinated approach
hopefully we can help facilitate that
and uh enable that and say
it's a new public realm for bubbly that
start
to is um it's on the high street it's
the old
co-op site um next to the um
the current uh supermarket again this
has been
vacant and derelict for quite a decade
um we we just want to see this
redeveloped with um active uses
on the ground floor so retail commercial
uses on the ground floor again to give
that vibrancy
to you to study
okay so there are then um
five um rural uh proposals
uh first one here one is napton
brickworks again
uh north is to the right so this is a
uh deronic site brownfield site
we're looking to bring this forward for
primarily residential but by doing so we
could then enable
a creation of a news wildlife area as
well
again thoughts welcome on the
appropriateness of this proposal
rural two north is to the right
uh so this is well as one campus so this
is
uh north of wells born itself you can
see the
north west of wells one i should say um
you can see wells born just at the
bottom left of the map there
[Music]
uh directly to the left uh that shulker
um village is uh
to the top of the map which would be uh
west um encompass points
um so this is the site of the university
of warwick as well as on campus
uh the council is keen to support the
university my cat's just gonna
come across the screen in a minute so
apologies if you get a
fairy tale um the council is supportive
to the university um
investing in the campus and we want to
do what we can
for that and the the area is not hatched
where the
uh we think it's suitable for uh
that investment apologies
um that investment to take place
um for new new r b investments
um forth and then the the area of
hatching
um that sort of separated the far left
of
that just by the airfield that would be
a commercial development to help enable
you know fund
the uh the investment in the r d side of
things
um so some exciting proposals um at
wellsworth campus
so we're again keen to hear your views
on on that one please
um rule three which is the quentin rail
technology center down at
long lasting again north is to the right
just to orientate yourself so the
new community um being built up neon
vale
is to uh to the bottom of that map or
uh to the east um
and then that's um sort of vertical line
for not let's call that um horizontal
line diagonal
horizontal line uh is the it's the
green way and the root the freight
branch
that runs uh the railway that runs down
to honeybourne
so what we're seeking to do here is to
safeguard
this the quentin real tech center
for railway related inward
investment to support growing economy
i understand it's the only the country's
only
rail loop test track we think it's of
national importance
we want to safeguard and encourage um
inward investment and development
on the for the railways industries
um and that's why we're uh identifying
the plan and be grateful for your views
on this one please um rule four
is the uh or the former
martin depot um the actual
um neon valley itself
the community was already there is the
the area to the
bottom right of that map and what we're
proposing here is exploring whether
there's any potential for additional
development
on the areas hatched um the site itself
is predominantly woodland um
it's not a designated wildlife site
although
uh we're investigating its status on
that one
um site um previously was
a part of the site i should say
previously
uh was identified for holiday
accommodations as part of the original
concept for
for me on vail um that's evolved
um we want your views as to whether we
should identify this part of the site
for uh housing um
i've seen doing so we would retain
those areas not earmarked which
seeks to strengthen those both in terms
of public access
and biodiversity
and to create a another i suppose a
phase five
to to meal now which has been a very
successful
community um in the district
um i want to just clarify that neon
valley is part of
the long martin depot site and uh
again similarly with the rule three the
railroad the whole site is identified as
a
larger brownfield site in the core
strategies as policy as11
um so obviously this bit of it is
greenfield
and what we're trying to do is resolve
if you like that conundrum of
greenfield site on brownfield
or greenfield land on a brown on a wider
brownfield site
so keen for your views as to whether
this is the right approach
um policy currently written uh is saying
up to a maximum of 300 homes which is
simply the
the extent of the hatched areas um
you know is that right balance uh we
need to understand the
the biggest biodiversity value of the
site
um there are also some other site
constraints
namely the uh the adjacent rail loop uh
make sure the noise from that
uh does not inversely affect any
potential future occupants
and we also need to resolve the flood
risk and the
highways issues so rule four
number of considerations to think about
but again we're just
asking the question is this is this a
proposal that
that you agree with i mean be grateful
for you for your comments on it
and lastly rule five which is long lost
airfield
we're calling it phase 1b and so
long muscle airfield itself is
identified as a
new assessment in the core strategy
that's the budget line and
then goes up the um the outside edge of
the the area marked um
the camden road there um
it's been identified in the core
strategy for three and a half thousand
homes
um you may recall that let's just
flick it flicker the core strategy at
the time the core strategy was prepared
uh the highway modeling um did show that
there was a
effectively a cap on the amount of
development
new housing that can be built at the
moment airfield south of stratford
and that cap was about 400 homes after
which we'd need
to build a relief road to enable
the sides as a whole to come forward
this is
policy lma um in in the course strategy
and you'll see that
um i've highlighted the last bullet
point there
which does acknowledge that um
southwest relief rates will be required
unless the transport assessment
demonstrates the higher threshold is
appropriate
now working with the county council
we have done some further highway
modelling
and that modeling does indeed show the
um there is slightly more capacity in
the network
that's because the assumptions used in
the previous model
have um haven't um uh
come haven't proved to be correct um so
there's more capacity in the network
than previously assumed
uh which means that we can um
deliver more homes at long-lasting
airfields than we previously thought
um now that modeling to be clear it was
done
pre-covered and so it's it's if
the the impacts of kovid and haven't
been taking account
so it's all pre-coding modeling and what
that modeling was
was suggesting was that it was the
ability to accommodate
um say we think another 500 homes um
at long last snare field so that's what
we're proposing
uh a phase one b if you like the phase
one
for 400 homes and we want to do it
through the site allocations plan my
cat's back
to ensure that we have a coordinated
approach to development
along with it will still deliver the
master plan and we still um
ensure that we get the infrastructure
that we need
to deliver the new settlements so it's
like a phase 1b
and of the existing um long lasting
airfield new settlement
and again thoughts uh thoughts on that
one welcome please
right uh okay
so that's the the other components of
the site allocations plan
um just to recap um
comments uh by the friday the 18th of
december please
that's the consultation deadline um the
documents are available at stratford.gov
dot uk forward slash
sapo sapo and
you can also view the interactive
document there you can
comment via the interactive document or
you can send any comments through to
policy docs
consultation hyphen dc dot dot uk
um or if you have any queries please do
email planning.policy at
stratfordhypendc.com
um so i hope that's been useful a bit
more background to
the content the sam why we're proposing
what we're proposing
uh just to reiterate this is a a draft
uh plan we are consulting on it we want
to hear your views
and say we will then take those views on
board before
preparing the next version and uh
consulting on
that proposed submission version so
we're still at early stages
um and we're looking forward to hearing
from you
but uh thank you for listening hope that
was informative
and do keep safe and well and see you
again soon
cheerio what was just about the cat as
well